[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a canadian comedy film called
starbuck
spoilers ahead eh watch out and take
care
[Music]
david wozniak is a young man living in
quebec canada he makes money by
frequently donating sperm to the la
france clinic at the beginning of the
movie he is in the middle of one of his
visits to the sperm bank pleasuring
himself to pictures of women in a
magazine the scene shifts to 23 years
later in 2011 david is now a middle-aged
man but he still doesn't have a definite
job he is woken up by thugs whom he owes
thousand dollars they dump him into the
bathtub threatening him to return their
money following the unusual morning he
goes to his parents butcher shop where
he works as a delivery man he is 45
minutes late and is yelled at for taking
the delivery truck home again the
workers in the shop along with his
father are on a football team and are
about to take a team picture the next
day david was told to pick up the
jerseys for the picture three weeks ago
but he still hasn't gotten it everyone
is tired of him not doing as told even
when the job is simple after work he
rushes to the clothing store but the
owner happens to be closing it just then
he quickly parks his truck in the middle
of the road and begs the owner to give
him the jerseys the man does it out of
sympathy but david gets a parking ticket
in the process following that he visits
several banks to ask for a loan to pay
off his debts however he doesn't have
the required collateral for them to pass
the loan after facing several rejections
he returns home and tells his co-worker
on the phone that he has received the
jerseys the person on the other end is
skeptical knowing that david isn't
reliable outside his truck is taken away
by the traffic police because he
received too many parking tickets the
jerseys were still in the truck which
means the team has to take pictures
without them everyone is disappointed in
david although they are used to his
behavior after that david goes to his
girlfriend valerie's house she is a
police officer and is way more
financially independent than david he
hasn't spoken to her in a few days which
valerie is upset about as david tries to
explain himself she reveals that she is
pregnant david is taken aback by the
revelation he cannot tell if he likes
the news or not valerie senses that he
is hesitant and claims that she is going
to keep the child no matter what
following the interaction david goes to
meet his friend the lawyer the lawyer
has four kids all of whom refuse to
listen to him he has been troubled by
fatherhood and suggests david not have
children ever in his life david however
wants to be a father he is only confused
if this is the right time for him the
very next morning he goes to valerie's
work and declares to her that he is
ready to be a father to their child upon
reaching home he meets a man in a suit
who introduces himself as chamberlain he
is the lawyer for the clinic that david
used to donate sperm to between 1988 and
1990 david donated sperm to the bank
under the name starbuck he made over
693 donations over the period of 23
months david spanked it once a day for
the horde because of some kind of error
the company provided all of its clients
with david's sperm and as a result he
has fathered
533 children out of them 142 want to
know his identity but before every
donation david had signed a
confidentiality contract according to
which the clinic isn't allowed to share
his personal information hence the 142
children who want to get to know their
father have sued the company and their
confidentiality clause so they would be
given the information about david
hearing all this david freaks out and
repeatedly says that he is not starbuck
after the encounter he goes to meet his
friend the lawyer and tells him about
the matter the lawyer wants him to file
a countersuit against the clinic and
make some money but david refuses to do
so he notes down all the information
about the sperm donation procedure and
hands david an envelope with information
about all of his children the next
morning david decides to take a look at
a paper inside the envelope out of
curiosity the paper he pulls out has
information about a star football player
ricardo donatelli david realizes that he
is the father of one of his favorite
players and rushes to tell the lawyer
they go to ricardo's game and cheer for
him now that david knows the player is
his son he is proud of his genes at
first he had decided that he wouldn't
get involved with his children's lives
but curiosity gets the best of him david
pulls out a second piece of paper and
gets to know about etienne his son who
works at a restaurant david goes to the
listed restaurant and finds etienne
arguing with someone on the phone it
turns out that he is a struggling actor
who has just missed an opportunity to
audition for a huge role because he is
working david offers to handle the place
for him while he goes to the audition
etienne believes he is a robber who is
looking for a tactic to rob their shop
but when offered the delivery truck to
go to the audition he agrees a while
later the restaurant's owner arrives at
the place and tells david he's going to
fire at tien hours pass before etienne
finally returns and says that he got the
part david is glad that he was able to
make a difference in his son's life at
night he brings out a third piece of
paper and finds out about his daughter
julie he goes to her place as a pizza
delivery guy and finds her on the phone
yelling at someone while he is still in
the house she locks herself in a room
and overdoses on a drug david quickly
has her sent to the hospital the next
day julie is sent to a rehabilitation
center where people assume that he is
her father julie doesn't reveal the
truth because she wants david to sign
the release papers as her father so she
can be let free david consults with the
doctor and tries to convince julie to
stay in rehab but the girl promises that
she will be better outside because she
just got her dream job yesterday and she
doesn't want to lose it at last david
decides to release her the next morning
he goes to her workplace and sees she
has started the job as she had promised
on returning home he pins the papers
with his children's information to the
wall and goes to meet them one by one
some of them have grown to be nail
technicians musicians lifeguards tour
guides and so on he meets them all and
goes out of his way to help them if they
need it one day valerie visits him at
the shop and asks him to come to the
doctors with her after the appointment
they go to a park and watch children
play valerie is scared about the
pregnancy and thinks that she is not
ready to be a mother david on the other
hand promises to be the best father and
comforts her the following day he finds
out that one of his children named
raphael is disabled he goes to the home
of disabled people and nervously talks
to his son raphael realizes that someone
is around but he is unable to talk or
respond because of his disability david
spends the day talking to him even
though the kid cannot reply he also
feeds raphael during lunch break the
next day while following his other son
david ends up at a meeting organized by
all the children who were born because
of starbuck
seeing all of his offspring in one place
overwhelms david and he stands up
involuntarily he is suddenly handed a
microphone and asked to speak david
tells them that he loves them and gives
a heartfelt speech about all of them
being siblings after the program he
meets julia etienne and other children
who he has helped to hide his identity
he pretends to be raphael's adopted
father the children have formed a
community of sorts and have started to
socialize with each other as
half-siblings when david returns home
that day he is again dumped into the
bathtub by the thugs to whom he owes
money at night one of his sons anthony
who has somehow found out about his
identity comes to his house he says that
he doesn't want to reveal david's
identity to the people and is only
looking to spend a few days with his
biological father david agrees to let
him stay at the house he and valerie go
to his parents house for dinner that day
as the table erupts into friendly
chatter david's father tells them about
the time david bought them tickets to
italy it turns out that his parents
hadn't had a chance to go on their
honeymoon so david used all the money
that he had collected from donating
sperm to take them on vacation although
no one knows where he got the money from
they praise his thoughtfulness valerie
looks at david differently after finding
out what he had done for his family then
david and anthony go to a football
practice together and enjoy a father-son
day the day goes well until david
mentions that he has to tend to his real
family now that valerie is pregnant the
following day david's children organize
a picnic they sing dance eat together
and have a lot of fun as siblings
however the day after the event the
story of starbuck catches the media's
attention although the children didn't
mean to make starbucks look bad the
media paints him as a pervert who used
his sexuality to make money when david
asks valerie what she thinks about
starbuck she claims that he's no
different from a prostitute the two get
into an argument about the matter one
day before a football practice the team
is talking about starbuck all of david's
teammates think he is a creep and a
pervert his brother asks him if he has
ever donated sperm but david denies
having done anything like that the
conversation gets heated when they
assume he is lying david almost attacks
his brother and has to be stopped by the
others
that evening he is informed that the
thugs whom he owes money threatened his
father and tried to drown him in the
bathtub if he doesn't pay off the debt
soon his entire family will suffer hence
david goes to the lawyer and says he
will file a countersuit against the
clinic for using his sperm unethically
he hopes that after winning the lawsuit
the clinic will provide him monetary
compensation the lawyer is happy to have
finally gotten a big case that will
bring him fame if he wins for the next
few days they work very hard to create a
strong case the night before the ruling
they play football in the pouring rain
to relieve stress the judge finally
announces that starbuck is entirely
entitled to his anonymity which means
the children will not get to see their
biological father unless he wants to
show himself deliberately david is also
entitled to receive a total of two
hundred thousand dollars for damages and
interest david celebrates the win from
his house while the lawyer is swarmed by
reporters congratulating him for the win
he expresses his gratitude to his mother
kids and accidentally says he is
thankful to david as well when the
reporters ask him who david is he claims
he is his boyfriend the children are
also interviewed about their thoughts
and opinions on starbuck they claim that
although they wanted to see their father
they understand if he wants to keep
living his life normally they also
declare that starbuck is not a freak or
a pervert that the media portrays him to
be in fact the children think that he is
a nice man who gave them life and a
chance to be happy david watches the
interview regretting that he cannot be a
father to all of his biological children
he wants to meet them as their dad but
is scared that he won't get the
compensation if he does so he meets the
lawyer who confirms that coming out as
starbuck is a great risk on returning
home that day david finds his father
waiting in the kitchen as they chat
david tells him that he is starbuck
unlike what he has expected his father
isn't disappointed or sad in fact he
advises david to tell everyone the truth
he also hands his son 80 000
as his part of the inheritance from the
butcher shop now that david has enough
money to pay off his debts he emails all
of his children about his true identity
that night valerie goes into premature
labor and gives birth to a healthy baby
boy david's father brothers along with
many of his children come to the
hospital to congratulate him they
embrace in a big group hug david tells
valerie about him being starbuck she
freaks out initially but eventually
accepts him as he is the baby gets
numerous presents from all of his
half-siblings in the end we see david
and the children in a subway supporting
one of their brothers who is a singer
good thing he has over 500 siblings
musicians these days need the support
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching